Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to "Lethe" or "Leeth," I'm not 100% sure how to pronounce it,
but this is supposed to be a very good horror game,
in the same style as the original Amnesia: The Dark Descent.
And that doesn't mean that it's an exact clone,
but that does mean that it's probably dark, creeping hallways,
with lots of close encounters with horrible monstrosities of all kinds.
I can't wait for it, because it's been a long time since we've had like a really good horror game,
Oh, my turn.
*reads on-screen text*
Well, wonderful for you, Robert Dawn.
*licks lips and made a "cluck" sound.
Oh, *reads on-screen text*
*reads on-screen text*
Oh, okay.  Weird.
*reads ominous text on-screen*
[ominous Inception music]
Well...  That music crescendo-ed at the right time!
And I LOVE... I LOVE me a good musical score!
Like, I can't liv- ohh, shit.
Ah, shit dude!
Uh oh!
What happened?
I'm assuming something bad happened...
and I'm on the verge of death.
Hello?
It me.
From other side.
Are you there?
Oh, holy shit.  Okay!
Ohh, I'm so ready.
Oh, I'm so excited!
Oh, what is- EUAH.
Oh, hi.
What is that?
Is that a statue or a dildo?  I can never tell.
Ugh...
K.
Okay.  Oh, hello- Hi!
Oh shit, I thought that was footsteps.
Hang on, it's too early to-oOooOOOOOookay!
By Odin's beard!
Oh, jeez!  Okay!
That's a little peculiar.
Ohhh...
And it looks good, too- Ow, was that through my hand?
I'm so tickled.
Ah'm so excaited.
What's happening?
Yep, that went through my hand alright.
Ouchies!
Ouchie-kabibbles.
I better pull that out, probably.
Eugh.
Eugh.  Egh!  Ugh!!  Eugh...!!
*with sarcasm* Thank you, orchestra.
I needed to know that really hurt.
Okay.
Let's get into it then.
Ah, yes.  Okay.
A little bizarre.  "Wuh-sahd"  to walk around.
Okay...
So, what is this?
Huh- Oh, shit.
*reads letter on-screen*
Ahh, so my father wasn't actually my father.
My father was an adoptive father.
Ohh, that's pretty!
OH, that's pretty!
Oh, look! I get a lantern!
Ohh, it's glowy!!
Oh wait, no.  Aww, I thought I got that.
Aw, I thought that was gonna be mine!
I thought I was gonna have it for mine...
Aw, man.
I'm so excited- And I don't wanna make too many comparisons to what Amnesia was...
Uh, because it would be unfair to this game to say it's only just like Amnesia.
And I want to treat this game as if it's its own entity.
But...
Tha- I'm just going based on what I saw in the reviews,
and so I-I don't mean to be unfair or draw a different conclusion.
*gasp* I can eat!
Ohh!  I'm recovering hulth!
Oh, good.
*reads letter on-screen*
Well I mean, you could hop on a boat and maybe get the fuck outta here.
Oh, man.
Why did someone leave that knife in that rabbit?
Alrighty then.
Wooooh...
Hellooo.
Ohh, it's so cool.
Can I pick things up?
Ah, dammit, no physics-based...
Okay.
Alright, hello.
*reads letter on-screen*
Probably aliens.
That said "Greek" on it, does it--eugh.
SORRY!!
Sorry about your ancient Greek pottery!
...I just shattered...
Ooh, dark in here.
Hello.
Ah, yes.
Hi~i!
Whoa...
Okay... (More noises)
Ahh, that dudn't look good.
Oh, that looks...
That looks patently bad.
That looks like a barrel from Half Life.
I don't wanna know what's under there.
*reads letter on-screen*
Aww, it's kinda sad.
Oh, more - more Greek spaghetti in a can!
Oh, I'll just eat the can whole!  Shove it straight down mah gullet!
I ain't need to worry about nothin' else.  I can digest aluminum same as the best of 'em.
Oh, boy.
Wow.
Okay...
So, I'm guessing those are the entrance to the mines?
And this house is kin- *HOOOOO* FuCkINg COCK
Well!
A~alright!
Let me just get my heart started back up again!  Hup!  Hup!  Hup!
Okay, I think I'm okay.
Wow.  Why the hell was that there?
What could that have possibly prevented?
I have no goddamn idea, but there's another one over here, already covered with blood...
from another unfortunate soul that stomped his way, heavy-footed, over this way.
A~aanywaay!
Into the thick of it I go again, watching out for more bear traps.
Heart attack bear traps.
"Walk up to a ladder to climb it."  You got it, buddy-boo!
Alright.
So, what is this- AGH!  FUCK OFF!!
*sigh*
Jeezums.
Just eat- eat everything in sight, and get smashed on by everything.
Jeezum- *gasp*
Oh, I thought that was gonna be another one!
'Kay, so there's...
some swatches here.
Ahh, bejeezums.
Oh, bejeezums!
Oh, good lordy bejeezums!
Okay, I don't know what this did.
If it did anything at all.
[machine turns on]
Huh-booooooooooooom!
[machine hums]
Okay.
Is that good?
Huh-boop.
M-okay!
Lookin' on the ground!
Tryin' to be more mindful of everything!
I'm probably gonna hit another goddamn bear trap!
Just like in everything I do.
I remember, I was playing Dead By Daylight with the boys, and uh...
I kept running into some goddamn bear traps that I obviously knew were there, but...
That footage was one of- one of the many footage that I lost, unfortunately.
Which is very sad, because getting my new recording set-up up and running has been a bit of a...
a bit of a byatch, but I'm getting it.
Oh, okay!
Oh, so that opened up.
Ohhh!
I-I didn't know I need to go this way arou- eugh.
Alright.
So far, so goo.
*reads letter on-screen*
Yeah, he's probably dead!
Didn't get enough spaghetti in a can, if you ask me.
Okay, so... Oh, why is there just a lonely chair out by the...out by the shore over here?
Oh, shit.  Sorry!
Sorry!
Ah shit sorry!
Aah, jeez
I'm fucking everything up
I apologize to everyone
I'm just a god damn screwup that's what I am
Alright, so I don't think there's anything else over here...
I don't have any sort of flashlight, so it's going to be difficult to explore anyway...
...and I think this was just a back way into the normal place that I was going already...
So there must be the answers somewhere over here
So I'll be right back once I figure out the next place I'm supposed to go
Oh, hello. Oh!
*reads text on-screen*
... I hear it's been a real mess down there lately." Okay, so...
Huh.
*confused* Huh?
Aaahhhh, okay!
[while cargo crane descends loudly] Oh jeezums. Oh gash.
Okay, so, what that did...
"Use the spacebar to jump," okay I get that, but I think - don't I need to - ?
Hup hup, hup.. hup, hup.. HUP!
HABUP!
Oh, no, I need to go over HERE.. ohh, okay!
HABOOSKY!
Is there gonna be another bear trap anywhere over here?
...I'm about to get blasted in the ass again.
....alrighty then
eugh, stop that
Alright... so far, so clear
...runnin'
*reading from screen* "Warning. Keep hands clear from machinery."
How 'bout.. noooo?
How 'bout I stick my  hands right in there... uh-oh
Well, that didn't do nothin'
That did jack-squaddly-dick
*reading from screen* "Danger. High Voltage. No trespassing."
..daaangahh.. hiiigh voltage..
*noticing prompt to sprint* Oh. Why would I need to sprint?
I always get very wary when they tell me how to sprint!
*reading text on-screen*
Have I, now...
Oh, goodness..  I'm gonna go in anyway, because I'm a BALLER like that
Okay, so I have a funny feeling I'm supposed to smash open the gates here?
At least, that's just my understanding about how this all works
So, there's gotta be a way to release this trolley-type device and have it go schlammy-bammy into that wall
WHERE'S THE SLAMMY-BAMMY SWITCH? Oooh, is it here? ...okay
Somethin' over there...
... and there's somethin' over there, and I WOULD believe
..and I would believe that that switch probably releases this thing and causes it to go careening forward
But I'll get to that in a second, because I believe there's more to explore..
..down yonder way, so give me two seconds, and I'll go over here..
into the area where it said I might need to know how to sprint!
w - hey, fuck you. What're you doin'? What are you? WHAT ARE YOU?
You couldn't have come out of the mines, I don't know what you are!
Eugh... alrighty then
Well...
..fancy-wancy..
Hello! Ohhh, god
..hello...
[sound of bear trap clanging shut]
AGHH FUCK OFF!!
...WITH THE STUPID BEAR TRAPS!!
OW!
WHY?! They put those there intentionally because they think I'm stupid!
..AND I AM!!
*sigh*
*reading text on-screen*
Whoops
*continues reading text on-screen*
*singing* WE'RE GOIN' HOME!
*finishes reading* ..Mike." Love, Mike.
Okay, so...
...There's no machinery over there, what am I gonna keep my hands clear of?
Okay, so I'm imagining
[wheel squeaking]
..that if I turn these things on, it's gonna get steam to the thing
And then there's g- ooohh.
Oh, shit.
Well, somethin' happened. There's gonna be -
...shit
Yum yum yum yum yum
There's gonna be steam to the thing, and there's danger over here, 'cus - eugh
Eugh.
[weird liquid sizzling]
AH! OKAY DON'T TOUCH THAT
WEIRD LIQUID IS BAAAD
Okay, so
But that put steam over on the thingy
And so now the thingy should be able to get gone
And blast it... all the way to the thing.
Right? Did that make sense - probably not - here we go - KAPLOINK
[cart surges forward] WAHOOO!!
Goddamn! Holy shit!
That thing had some oomph!
That thing had some major oomphage!
Okay.. so follow the trail of oomphage into here...
And then.. ohhh, I guess we're goin' in now.
Ooh boy.. ooh Nelly
..ooh Nelly... oh, boy
Oooh hello. Hi. Big red button?
Oh, can't press you! Okay.
Goin' further down - ow, oop, sorry
Okay, good then..
Hi? I can't move! WHAT'RE YOU DOIN'
Okay....
You scanning me?
Can you see me naked right now?
Oh...
Well that's a little bizarre
Okay...
[machine makes loud buzzing noise]
wooooah
I don't know what I did...
...but it seemed like it was important and my clumsy hands probably broke it
Alrighty then...
So that's green.. but let me see what's up over here first
PROBABLY another bear trap
...can of food...
Huh.
I don't see anything too important... AH! Okay.
[gate squeaking] Squeaky!
Alright, what's on over here?
[door opening]
Ahh! Loading screen
*reads text on-screen*
Yeah! INTO THE MINES, where every note said about all the death poisoning...
alright...
I-I-I also noticed there's a little, like, note counter in the bottom left, which I'm assuming is - is for all the notes that I can find
I don't know if I found all of them in the last one
I'm gonna TRY to be.. very observant, but you know me, I get distracted way too easily
...what was that?
...okay... habadoo..
HELLOOOOO... it's ME! MARKIMOO!
...hello?
okay
Eugh, someone's taking a bath over there
Is anybody in here... no? No one? Okay
Eugh...
I w- I actually do wonder if they're ever gonna give me a lighting-type device
Ohh boy.. oh boy
Also, I-I-I will admit I love the slow introduction that this game is giving, like the slow pacing and the slow introduction to the world?
Uhm
It - It's definitely nice, and I appreciate the cramped corners that it's forcing me into
*reads text on-screen*
Well, it seems like that didn't help because apparently everyone is dead anyway...
Alright, so
This game also said that it'd have an emphasis on puzzles... which we all know...
...when it comes to puzzles, Markimoo is smarty-poo!
Oh.. alright
Uh-huh..
...okay
So I don't know if that was supposed to be the last... tutorial
...hello
[another bear trap clangs shut]
AGH! FUCKING COCK
*sigh*
Greaaaaaaaat.
*sarcastically* so HAPPY about that
..alright what did that do
Put steam on... apparently
God damn it, when am I gonna learn?
LOOK DOWN!
Not that I'd even be able to see it in the darkness, it's completely pitch-black around here
...That sounds bad
Given my experience with these types of games, I-I-I feel like I can recogni -
AHHHH! I GOT YA!
Hohoho - how am I supposed to get around that? It's..
..literally... literally the only direction to go
Can I go - can I jump over it? Probably not
EuUH
Okay, okay, we made it! *chuckles*
Euugh, alright.
..okay
*reads text on-screen*
Uh-huh.. okay.. fuckin'..
fuck, fuck.. let me at the food! [nom] I want mah munchies!
Oh, boy... damn
I-I feel like.. Oh, I thought that was like a crouchy place I could go down into
That would've been bad - okay
eUH
Ahhh - okay. We're fine. Everything's fine.
Okay, that's locked up
Alright... Ohh, that looks dangerous. Is this bad?
Okay, it's not deadly water
..but probably not - eugh, EUGH, oh god, oh GOD
Euugh, I just realised, I'm just crouching in a pile of poop!
EUGGH!
Why - there's so many mushrooms, I probably am infected with the disease now
Greaaaaat
Oh, boy
Ah! Fuuuu...
...okay..
what the fuck was that?
Fuck off!
okay.. who knocked this door down?
..oh
..ah.
...yes, lovely. Lovely, all this. Definitely lovely.
Eugh
Oh!
Okay!
Yeah, sure, okay!
*confused* ...Did I go the right way?
I don't feel like it..  *seeing bear trap* I see you! I see you!
Alright, turned another one on...
So, I'm just cranking up all these steam generators around here
And hopefully... they're gonna lead me to where I need to go.
Ahhhh okay. Okay. Alright, I think I got it.
Hello
*reads text on-screen*
[Markiplier gasps for air]
*continues reading text on-screen*
YEAH..
..like horrifying experimentation of the worst type!
[the elevator power control shorts out]
*reading* "Elevator power control"
Oop, well, that shitted out
Okay but that leads back into the main area, where I was before
So there must be another puzzle down here, to get the elevator working, which is probably gonna help me get farther down in the mine...
Looks like they're out of yellow goop!
I need to find a way to get more yellow goop in here!
Oh this IS the elevator, okay, so there's probably something else in this facility that has all of the yellow goop storage
I just need to get to it.
Oooh, this door is open now. Hello?
Oh, it's dark - oh no, I've been here. Okay, I've been here.
That's the - uh - other door for the elevator control
Okay, so this went through - woooh
Darker than I remember in here... did I go in here?
Maybe, maybe not.
Man, I'm already getting turned around just because I'm not familiar with this place
...okay...
[door creaks open] Eugh, eugh, EUGH!
THAT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD
THAT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD AT AAAALLL
Oh, those are flies, I thought those were moans of the damned
[moaning sound] THAT'S THE MOANS OF THE DAMNED
HoOoLY SHIT
AAGH!!
WHERE DO I GO, WHAT DO I DO
AM I OKAY?
Euuuuugh.... euuuugh.... euuugh... euugh... eugh.
Okay, what was that?
Was that a whole lotta nothin'?
It was probably nothin'.
[door opening]
Hello? Nothing?
HELLOOooOO
IT ME!
Okay - ah, good, yes, very thunky
[rumbling as the gate lifts]
Oh, excellent!
...oh.
Ohhh
Ohh, I don't like that
Ohhh, I don't like that at all
Oh, jeez
Oh, jeez, Scoob
*laughing* Oh come on!
Don't do that!
Don't DO that!
DON'T DO THAT
OOOoooh
Okay!
This is what you would call bad
Hmmm....
[gate creaks]
Ah, hello other bear trap
I see you this time
Fool me six times, shame on you...
..fool me seven, shame on me
*reads text on-screen*
Okay!
What was this to? It doesn't even have a label on it
I can only assume this powered something good...
[Markiplier gasps]
fuuUUUCK OFF
WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU?!
[sounds of running/dripping water]
HI FRIEEEEEND
Wanna be FRIENDS?!
[more sounds of water]
Eugh...
[yet more sounds of water running, this time with ominous moans in background]
That doesn't sound good!
Woah, that doesn't sound good -
AGH! FUCK OFF! WHAT WAS THAT?!
*relieved sigh*
...I'm okay
Man, 90% of all the scares in this game so far have just been me scaring myself
...like an idiot...
...which is what I am
...very much - what is that?
What is that?
*confused, reading from screen* "...consume health supplements"?
Ohh, man
Better than food, I suppose!
[Markiplier splashes into the water]
Woooah, okay, very thunky
Hello... alrighty then
Eugh.. m -ohh!
Hi!
Oh my god! It's that guy from Amnerrrshurrr
...towards the end
BUMBO? Was his name Bumbo?
YEAH, it was Bumbo
Good old Bumby
Bumby bumbo
Ohh boy
Bumba-lumba-bumbo...
..bumba-lumba-bumbo
Hello!
It me! Again.. Am I back to where I was before?
*reads text on-screen*
Why not just run away?!
[machine buzzes]
Okay...
So that's some sort of saaaving mechaaanic of sooome sort?
Eugh... hello, health supplement
...how are you?
Good. [nom] thank you
Okay
I'm assuming they're giving me these because I'm about to encounter some.. anti-health people
....some anti-health devices
*quietly* ...'kay
So this just leads back to...
...that main room area
[ominous, creepy breathing]
Hhhhiiii...
I can do that too!
*makes moaning sound*
Am I good enough to join the choirs of the damned?
...Okay, let's see if the elevator will power up now
Aaaahh! That's probably good sounds, when the entire Earth shatters
...okay. Well, I'm off!
See you ass... bags later!
..or I'll probably just see you in the next area
Okay!
An overly dramatic entrance into the elevator, but that's okay! I won't judge ya
Goodbye!
Goodbye forever!
Sayonara!
See you later!
Ohh, we're just now doing the intro credits, are we?
Ohh, that was just an introductory period, was it?
Oh ho HO ho!
Heh HEH heh
...I'm not even gonna try to pronounce that name
Ugh...
Wait, it just dawned on me, that name was Stefanou... Stefanooooh
Oh boy... Man, I think these names are Greek?
I think that's why all the references in the game are Greek
But either way this is off to a great start, a wonderful start
...and I can definitely see the parallels to Amnesia?
And heck, maybe the game was a little bit inspired by it, but I'm not gonna... like I said, I don't wanna be too heavy-handed about it
Oh... oh! It lovely!
Ahhh... aw shhhhhit.. it's gonna - it's gonna drop me, isn't it?
Is it?
Am I free to go?!
[As elevator starts to drop] Oh, no!, Oh, there was food!
*laughing* and sunlight!
Oh god... here we go!
Three.. two.. one..!
[as music reaches crescendo] KERCHUNK!
There we go! *laughing*
Ohhhh boy.
Ohhh fu - yep, here we go
[elevator crashes]
And, dead. Instantly dead. That's the end of the game, everyone's dead.
...Everyone being me. And all the monsters too. They're dead, hopefully
Oh, boy
*reads text on-screen*
...Where is everybody?"
How the fuck would I know, I just got here!
I don't know what's happening! I have no idea!
Oh, man
Oh. where am I now - oh, good! I'm greeted by a skellington.
Mmmm...
That's good, that's a good start. Okay.
So actually, I'm gonna end this episode here
This is off to a phenomenal start
I mean, even though I've only been scaring myself, it's a good sign when the game sets it up so well?
... that I just end up scaring myself because I'm so paranoid about the environment
And this is looking to be a fantastic horror game, I cannot wait to play this -
And this is only episode one, I don't know how long the episodes are
But it looks like it's going to be a long, and very enjoyable experience
So THANK YOU everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought in the comments below
And as always, I will see YOU.. in the next video!
BUH-BYE!